enough guards crossed the pontar in the  East means Wars coming  War Changes Everything by order of the  hierarchy whosoever conceals a mage in  their home shall burn alongside him or  her  [Music]  nilfgaard on One Bank redania on the  other drooling over the city like dogs  over a juicy bone  exactly  we are at War and she's in danger  you will find her and bring her to me  she's a child of the Elder blood see now  I've gotta find Siri  why are you helping her because she's a  danger a mortal one a power that can  destroy the world you must find her  geralt  before the wild Hunt does  [Music]  [Applause]  we'll find her or someone who knows what  happened to her  who are you  you know who I am  a legend cannot be killed can it  the wild Hunt will be here soon  [Music]  foreign